[موسيقى]
البدايه اليوم من التكنولوجيا ومع تعديل
قانون امريكي قد يغير عالم الانترنت
بالنسبه لنا ولكم وللجميع رقم القانون 230
وستناقش المحكمه العليا تعديله للمره
الاولى اليوم الفكره الاساسيه المطروحه
لتعديل هي عدم مسؤوليه المنصه عن المضمون
الذي ينشر عليها القانون الذي ظل مسار جدل
منذ اعتماد عام 19
00 مهدد اكثر من اي وقت مضى بان يعدل
وربما يلغى ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ببساطه انه
سيكون هناك ملاحقات قضائيه بالجمله ضد
منصات الانترنت والتواصل لنتذكر مثلا هجوم
على المسجد في نيوزيلندا وتصويره مباشره
او تجنيد الاطفال في داعش كل ذلك حصل على
الانترنت على كل حال مزيد عن ما هو قانون
230 الذي شكل علم الانترنت الحديث مع
الزميله للتسليمه
المحكمه العليا الامريكيه امام قرار وصف
بالتاريخ سيعيد تشكيل عالم الانترنت عبر
اعاده النظر في الماده 230 من قانون اصلاح
الاتصالات السلكيه واللاسلكيه الامر الذي
سيغير طريقه الحديث عبر الانترنت ومواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي الى الابد
[موسيقى]
سيقرر القضاه ما اذا كانت عائله طالب
جامعي امريكي قتل في هجوم ارهابي في باريس
يمكنها مقادرات جوجل التي تمتلك موقع
يوتيوب بسبب الادعاءات بان خوارزميه توصيه
منصه الفيديو ساعدت المتطرفين في نشر
رسالتهم اما القضيه الثانيه فهي ضد شركه
تويتر وتركز ايضا على مسؤوليه الشركه عن
المحتوى المنشور على منصه التغريدات
القصيره
[موسيقى]
26 كلمه وضعت في قانون لاصلاح الاتصالات
السلكيه واللاسلكيه عام
1996 سمحت لشركات مثل جوجل وتويتر وفيسبوك
بان تصبح عملاقه فهذه العباره القانونيه
حمد هذه الشركات التي تستضيف التريليونات
الرسائل من المقادات من قبل شخص يشعر بانه
مظلوم بسبب شيء نشره شخص اخر سواء كانت
شكواه مشروعه ام لا
يرى البعض ان تويتر والفيسبوك ومنصات
التواصل الاجتماعي الاخرى اساء استخدام
هذه الحمايه ويجب ان يفقدوا هذه الحصانه
خاصه ان الماده 230 تسمح للمنصات
الاجتماعيه بتعديل خدماتها عن طريق ازاله
المشاركات التي تنتهك المعايير الخاصه
بالخدمات طالما انها تتصرف بحسن نيه
ريتا سليمان صباح العربيه واشنطن
جدل وقضايا عده اثارها قانون 230 الامريكي
ابرز القضايا قضيه الشابه الامريكيه
في اعتداءات باريس عام 2015 حيث قدم
والدها شكوى ضد جوجل المنصه يوتيوب بسبب
بروز تنظيم داعش من خلال اقتراحات مقاطع
مصوره لبعض المستخدمين الامر الذي اعتبر
دعما للتنظيم الارهابي القضيه الثانيه
رفعتها عائله الاردني نورس العساف وهو
الذي قتل بهجوم اسطنبول ارهابي عام 2017
حيث تدعي اسرته ان المنصات التواصليه مثل
تويتر وجوجل وفيسبوك سمحت لداعش
باستخدامها وبالتالي التحريض على الارهاب
وفي عام 2021 اعرب القاضي المحافظ كلارنس
رومانس عن اسفه لان المحاكم فسرت القانون
230 بشكل فضفاض ومنحت حصانه واسعه جدا
لبعض اكبر شركات الانترنت في العالم مثيرا
جدلا كبيرا لكن شركه التكنولوجيا وعلى
راسها متى تحذر من تعرضها للملاحقات ربما
يجعلها عرضه لشكاوي المتواصله لا تنتهي
[موسيقى]
من عمان ينضم لنا الخبير في امن المعلومات
رايت سمور سيد رائد اهلا بك معنا في
العربيه القانون 230 يحمي منذ ربع قرن
الانترنت ومنصات التواصل من الملاحقه
القضائيه الى اي مدى تعديل هذا القانون
سيغير من عالم الانترنت
صباح الخير
حقيقه العنوان الرئيسي للفقره انه سوف
يغير شكل الانترنت في العالم نعم هذا هذا
هذا الواقع الذي سوف يصبح عليه شركات
تتمتع بحصانه مده 27 سنه لحد الان حول
المحتوى المنشور عليها
لا يمكن مقاضاتها او ملاحقتها قضائيه على
المحتوى الذي يتم نشره على هذه المنصات
بالتالي هي كانت تتمتع بهذه الحصانه الان
سوف تفتقد هذه الحصانه بشكل كبير او بشكل
كلي
اذا سوف ترتد على المستخدم وسوف تكون هناك
شروط استخدام وشروط او اذونات استخدام
للمستخدمين جديده يتحمل فيها
المستخدم كل المسؤوليه حول ما يتم نشره
اذا ما تم مقاضاه المنصه
فهناك حق للمنصه ان تقاضي المستخدم هذا
واحد انا اعتقد انه سوف يرتد على حريه
التعبير
بمعنى انه حريه التعبير سوف تتقيد
بمنظومات الاي اي اللي الذكاء الاصطناعي
بملاحقه المحتوى الذي من الممكن ان يسبب
اي ملاحقه قضائيه للمنصه بالتالي سوف يكون
شكل المحتوى مختلف تماما خليني بس انا
كمان افهم شغله لما بنحكي احنا عن حصانه
حصانه للشخص للمستخدم ولا حصانه للمنصه
والعملاق التكنولوجي نفسه لانه مثلا كان
في كتير اتهامات لتيك توك في السابق
بالتحريض على العنف وفي حالات لقتله
وانتحار اطفال يتم فقط ادانه لهذه المنصه
بدون توجيه اتهامات وبدون عمل فعلي ملاحق
قانونيه
لا هي هي الحصانه للمنصه الحصانه اللي
المنصه وطبعا الحصاني هنا ما جاءت من من
فراغ وانما جاءت هذه الحصاني لاسباب
واسباب الحقيقه هي الها ارتباط امني
ارتباط بالامن القومي الامريكي هذه
المنصات كانت تزود يعني وكالات الامن
القومي الامريكي بكم هائل جدا من
المعلومات بالتال بالخلفيات هذه هذه في
برامج خاصه تحدث عنها ادواردسن في كتابه
لحتى في البلاك ميرور تحدث عنها وقال انه
هذه هذه
المعلومات مناجم المعلومات التي يتم تزويد
مؤسسات الامن القومي الامريكي بها هذه
يعني تعطي
العذر
بمنح هذه المنصات
الحصاني حول ما يتم نشره عليها بمعنى
الحصاني فقط للمنصه وليست للمستخدم بدليل
انه المنصه تستطيع ان تشطب وتعدم اعدام
رقمي بشكل مباشر اي حساب بما فيهم حساب
رئيس الولايات المتحده امريكيه دونالد
ترامب بالتالي يعني ما كان في اي نوع من
الحصانه للمستخدمين وانما كانت الحصانه
فقط تتركز على المنصه سيد رائد فقط بين
المدافعين عن هذا القانون وبين الذين هم
ضده يعني المدافعين عنه يقولون انه
بالاخير منصات التواصل ليست هي محرره
المحتوى وبالتالي يجب ان تتمتع بحصانه
قانونيه في المقابل من هم ضد القانون يرون
انه هذه المنصات حتى وان لم تكن محرره
للمحتوى فهي تقوم بالتوصيه وبالدعايه لهذه
الفيديوهات تنصح الناس لمتابعتها وقد تكون
فيديوهات
مثيره للجدل كفيديوهات داعش التي شاهدناها
واثارت الجدل ومن هنا فلابد من محاسبه
ومقاظات نشاط التواصل انت مع من الراي
يعني انا بالنص انا احمل المسؤوليه للمنصه
وبحمل لانه المنصه بتلعب بالخوارزميات
المنصه مسؤوله عن انتشار هذا الخبر المنصه
هي التي توصل هذا الخبر الى اكبر عدد ممكن
من الناس فبالتالي المسؤوليه مشتركه ما
بين المنصه وما بين صانع المحتوى ذاته
احمل المسؤوليه للطرفين وليس لطرف دون
الطرف الاخر هذه يعني حقيقه انه انا صاحب
محتوى لكن من ينشر هذا المحتوى ومن يتبنى
نشر هذا المحتوى اذا كان يخدم مصالح
سياسيه معينه او مصالح امنيه معينه يتم
نشره بشكل واسع جدا هنا
المسؤوليه مسؤوليه مشتركه ما بين صانع
المحتوى وما بين ناشر هذا المحتوى
وخوارزميات هذا المحتوى
خوارزميات طبعا سريه هذه لا يمكن نشرها
ولا يمكن اعطائها وتعتبر سر من اسرار حتى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
فعمليا بشكل عسكري يعني الرسمي بشكل سري
فعمليا هذه الخوارزميات وهذا المحتوى هم
عليهم ولديهم مسؤوليه مشتركه بشكل كامل
حول هذا رايي الشخصي حول يتم مشروع عبر
اراءك كمان شو رايك انه يصير الذكاء
الاصطناعي هو الرقيب والحسيب اليوم في في
مواقع عمالقه التكنولوجيا خصوصا انه
الشركات مش قادره تلحق يعني كل
هالمستخدمين شو راح ينشروا وما راح ينشروا
لا هو الحقيقه الان من يتابع المحتوى هو
الذكاء الاصطناعي يعني في حالات معينه في
حالات فرديه يتم التدقيق عندما يعترض صانع
المحتوى على تقييد هذا المحتوى يتم
التدقيق يدويا عليه لكن عن طريق بشري لكن
الجل المحتوى ومراقبه المحتوى بشكل هالعام
هي تعتمد على الذكاء الاصطناعي وانا اعتقد
انا اعتقد انه هذه مرحله مرحله انتهت من
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي وانا تحدثت فيها
معكم في قبل حلقه سابقه بالصباح العربيه
وقلت ان شكل منصات التواصل الاجتماعي سوف
يتغير
بشكل كامل ان كان على مستوى صناعه المحتوى
وان كان على مستوى نشر هذا المحتوى وان
كان على مستوى مراقبه وفلتره هذا المحتوى
بالتالي انا اعتقد ما دام انتهت هذه
المرحله سوف يتم التخلي عن الماده 230 من
الامريكي وبالتالي سوف نذهب الى خوارزميات
جديده والى شكل جديد من الانترنت وشكل
جديد من منصات التواصل الاجتماعي واصل
خبرنا التالي على الخوارزميات على كل حال
شكرا في امن المعلومات رايت سمور شكرا
جزيلا لك دائما